there's only one wall the grid here's
what we know about the White Walkers and
the Great War the White Walkers have
emerged as a single greatest threat and
the main antagonist in Game of Thrones
the best protection the realm has
against these supernatural forces is the
wall but what's going to happen when it
comes crashing down let's go back to the
very first scene in the series where
members of the Nights Watch are attacked
by a white Walker and a white we learn
right away that there is a mysterious
force of undead beyond the wall and that
the dead can rise again pay it is for
the long night when the White Walkers
move through the woods
this isn't someone else's war it's our
war because Gil Mormont and Jon Snow
both understood that the real war isn't
between of hips waddling houses it's
between the living and the dead the army
of the undead is led by the night king
and his fellow White Walkers these
supernatural beings lead an army of
whites unfortunate people the night King
has resurrected we saw this happen at
hardhome
where the night king resurrected the
wildlings killed in the massacre
thanks to a scene in season 4 we also
know that the night king can turn human
babies into white walkers
so where did the White Walkers even come
from we learned their origin story in
season six the White Walkers were
created by the children of the forest as
a defense against mankind who were
destroying their homes the children
actually turned a man into the first
white Walker using a blade of
dragonglass
or obsidian but this backfired when the
White Walkers broke free of their
control and started killing everybody
they now reside in the land of always
winter way up north on the continent of
Westeros so why can't the White Walkers
just waltz right into Westeros the wall
is made up of more than just ice
thousands of years ago the children of
the forest teamed up with the humans to
fight the white walkers and they built
the wall using ice and magic the Nights
Watch has guarded it ever since so we're
good right
not quite remember when bran was grabbed
by the night king this enabled him to
break the magical barrier in the
three-eyed Ravens cave and the night
king was able to find brand and his
friends so does this mean that when
brand passes under the wall the night
king will be able to follow we'll have
to wait and see in current day Westeros
most people have long forgotten about
the White Walkers and believe them to be
a mere legend told to frighten children
most of the ruling Westeros have had
their minds on the Iron Throne
ignorant of the great war to come one of
the few groups that seems aware and
worried about the night king are the red
priests and priestesses of Rahl er the
Lord of Light you've seen the night
kingdoms know you know the great war
still to come you know the army of the
Dead will be upon us soon Daenerys has
been sent to lead the people against a
darkness in this world and then the
great wars took both of these red
priestesses believe John and Danny are
the prophesied prince that was promised
Ozora hide this warrior is said to be
the only one who can deliver the people
from the night King and the White
Walkers both characters fulfill
different aspects of the prophecy so
we'll have to wait and see who actually
takes on this role to defeat the White
Walkers mankind is a few weapons at
their disposal
you can kill White's the resurrected
undead with fire but White Walkers are a
different story to destroy a white
Walker you need either Valyrian skills
like Jon Snow Sword long cloth or
obsidian aka dragon glass like the
dagger Sam Tarly used in season 3 it is
also believed that dragon fire could
kill a white Walker so we don't have
proof of this in the show yet we'll have
to wait for Daenerys dragons to come
face-to-face with a knight king's army
first Jon Snow's mission in season seven
will be convincing the rest of the realm
that not only our White Walkers real but
that their imminent descent on Westeros
needs to take priority over squabbling
over the Iron Throne it's clear that the
White Walkers are coming and that the
rulers of Westeros will have to turn
their eyes north because everything is
literally going to come crashing down we
can't wait to see what happens do you
want to hear more about how the history
of the White Walkers is different from
the book let us know in the comments
below